I tried to stop smoking with Chantix
remember those commercials right before
Ray Liotta died no it's like makeup on
he looks like a [__] scarecrow he's
like I can't believe I stopped smoking
with Chantix let's see it would you do
that challenge with me would you take up
smoking just to try Chantix yeah sure
that's that's some that's some YouTuber
[__] right there isn't it we got
addicted to analog I smoked camel
crushed cigarettes every day
I smoked a pack of Camel Crush every day
so I could review Chantix honestly and
here's what I find it works it tastes
amazing shout out to smash that like
super chat Super Chat me so I can
continue to buy more Chantix